this is my cute little hideout real hair
this is human hair yeah it's very simple
but it's quite
it's complicated a home without a mother
is a sad sad place
i do something called kosher zumba oh my
god she is my girl
that's mine there's nothing more than
just women
women are amazing when do you start
wearing wigs you grew up as a secular
jew correct but then you decided to take
it
up a notch acidic women don't feel a
need no one's telling them
that they're not enough this is a
gorgeous wig it has beautiful streaks
if there's one thing that the world can
learn from the hasidic woman is
what's going on now where are we okay
we're in toby's house toby's my sister
the best human in the world
she's the oldest human in the world in
our family the oldest human in our
family she has
12 grandchildren and counting she
doesn't look like she has grandchildren
look at her
yeah right is it possible no you're
great toby what do you what are you
making here
we're making kala for shabbos okay where
are we officer what are we doing
we're going in between bites because i
don't stop eating
we're going to check out a week place so
you get to see wigs
the only one that needs a wig here is me
[Laughter]
we're entering my nieces um here's um
week salon she does all my wigs for me i
purchased all my wigs from her
hey hi
how are you so pretty so this is a new
salon that you just moved to hello
okay so you get all these choices this
is a gorgeous wig
it has beautiful streaks highlights
so tell me about wig culture when do you
start wearing wigs so after you get
after you get married you need to cover
your hair okay so before marriage you
can
you go with your normal yeah before
before you're married
you can wear your own hair um and then
after you get married you have a choice
you can cover it with the card trick you
can cover it with a hat or you can cover
it with a wig
it becomes your identity becomes it kind
of becomes
who you are you know that's why i don't
change my wigs
because i feel like this is me so it's
my style and this
this is real hair this is human hair
yeah it's very simple but it's quite
it's complicated complicated right it is
complicated some people believe that it
doesn't make sense if you're taking
if you're supposed to be covering your
own hair to cover it with somebody
else's hair is not
okay even some people won't wear wigs
that's for that reason thankfully i i'm
from the community where we believe that
wigs are okay to wear
all right i gotta jump in here and offer
some clarification some rabbis think
wigs are better because they cover
everything
other rabbis say a kerchief is better
it's very complicated
so people within the community go with
what their personal
rabbi says i also want to mention that
unfortunately i had to remove a lot of
this
wig segment the the woman that's
pixelated didn't want to be seen
or heard in the video i found out this
afterwards
too bad because she was awesome on
camera she had a lot of interesting
things to say
but i understand and respect her
position a couple of fast facts
wigs usually cost six hundred to twenty
five hundred dollars
some women have one wig others have many
most of the wig hair is european
oh okay okay okay oh thank you
look every every community has its
strengths
and weaknesses is there something
hasidic women could teach the world is
there something
um i think you think that maybe others
are lacking in some way shape or form or
right well i just feel like as as a
woman don't don't try to
be something that something else i think
it's okay for women to be women
as in um the need to show that we can do
everything and that we can be more than
just women what's more than just women
there's nothing more than just women
women are amazing
and they're so powerful and they're so
great at what they do
at what they were naturally created to
do which is to be mothers and to be
nurturers
and to be and and there's no need to
try and show or prove
that you're more and that's because in
the world i think
the people are somehow of the opinion
that women are less or women can't do
everything that men can do so women are
so busy trying to prove that they can do
what men can do
stop it it's okay you're a woman you're
amazing
right a man can do what he can do and
women can do what they can do best
no guy can do what a woman can do why
isn't the guy trying to show that he can
do what women can do why are we
only women trying to show that we could
do what men can do
what's the point of that just be
comfortable in your skin be comfortable
of who you are and i feel like
aesthetic women don't feel a need no
one's telling them
that they're not enough and i know that
the world
thinks that women in the hasidic
community are
oppressed or they're looked down on or
they're not equal
that is so far from the truth we are
raised to believe
that we women are so strong we're so
powerful we're so amazing
we run the home we
we um hold for sound
you run the home we're the ones that
keep the family together
we're the stable strong part of the home
um our children need us so badly a home
without a mother is a sad
sad place and and we we're
we're we grow up understanding
our role as a beautiful beautiful thing
and we're not feeling a need to show
that we're guys
we're not it's okay right and you know
so i feel like if this one thing that
the world can learn
from the hasidic women is their comfort
in their skin
just being women and doing their
god-given role which is natural yes
there are women that could be
businessmen
yes there are women that can even do
plumbing i do plumbing
in my house i change light bulbs
i change it's not about that it's not
like we're stuck on making sure we do
only women's jobs it's not about that
but we're so comfortable and so happy to
be
women no we're not oppressed no we don't
feel like we want to be something else
so i i there are maybe some people who
have felt that
but i have to say the majority of women
in our community are just so comfortable
doing what they were born to do which is
to
be mothers and and just nurturers and
and wives
yeah and loving the people around them
and helping everybody
and you know being and you're you're
you're a creator you create video you
create
cinema right i found that i needed i
felt like i needed to use my creative
energy
yeah and um i'm an artist and i
you know i do painting and i i'm a
dancer and i and
and so i i started doing films as like a
side thing but
it's something that i do to fulfill my
creative side of me but but
who i am is not that okay who i am is a
is a mother or a wife is a this is a
person that's trying my best to be
close to god and as
as as as best human that i could
possibly can be
raising a generation of children that
will then
continue to make this world a better
place
um and and yeah
fear well done okay
that was a good one yeah you let it
loose
yes who is this
this is a guitar teacher in the
community
okay you teach guitar yes and play into
concerts and perform
she does performances and she's she's an
artist
a real artist well i had a couple of
artists here papa taught me guitar
and now she's teaching my kids guitar
[Music]
what were you telling me before i had
the camera off when i had the camera
that i was not born into the jewish
community here in
budo park okay i came from manhattan
and i grew up in a secular family with
professional musicians as
parents born jewish i had a christmas
tree in my home until i was 12.
and uh and my father said maybe it's
enough
and didn't let us have it anymore but
so you grew up as a secular jew correct
but then you decided to take it to up a
notch
right now yeah big time and so so tell
me why
tell us why why would you do that and
what have you gotten out of an amazing
knowledge
amazing there's nothing like it out
there
i tried i tried buddhism and i tried
catholicism
i tried a lot of different things and
what i was telling peter is and it
doesn't really matter what religion i
feel like people that are religious have
a better quality of life
100 because when you're connecting to a
higher
higher something everybody says that
they don't realize what they're talking
about though but that's the truth
when you connect to a power outside
yourself
you have a more meaningful feeling in
your life
and you realize that you're not innocent
i've never heard of it
someone's a secular jew and you you
basically go to the most extreme it
happens a lot more than you can
really so you feel
you're telling us that someone that
finds religion it's not about themselves
it's about connecting with the higher
power
but in judaism in particular if you are
a jew we believe
that there's a deep connection to
judaism it's in there you just have to
kind of like
scratch the surface in a way i find her
to be more
religious and authentic than me or she's
wearing a curtain chip which is hard for
me to do
i find that what she did is made way
harder than what i did because i grew up
religious
she didn't grow up religious and she
chose to be religious and that's that's
that's not easy
you know i grew up new at knowing i was
going to cover my hair and wear wigs so
it was something that we did i took it
for granted
and she's wearing a kerchief which which
i can't see myself wearing even though i
feel like it's a higher level
because wearing a kerchief isn't as
you know i don't know wigs are just
that's what everybody tells me but the
truth is
i i i i thought wearing a wood would be
really weird because i'm basically a
hippie at heart
okay and to hide your hair with
another set of hair it just seemed like
i don't know oxymoron i don't know what
the word is
but it seemed weird to me so i said nah
no i'm gonna just cover it you know
right well i came at the end of the
sixties
so i didn't really i wasn't really too
bad no but the
but the the sixties ideology the spirit
like grateful dead
that sort of thing yeah that's something
you were into the grateful dead a little
bit
not so much i i was into more like pop
okay there they were like i don't know
that i guess they're pop
i was more like the beatles and jimmy
hendrix so i
hired her to be on one of my um
performances that i did on a stage
okay and she was the guitarist on stage
and i fell in love with her parents she
didn't just
sarah amazing singer amazing singer she
was amazing singers
but nobody knows about them because
they're in the community they're within
the community right
she was playing a guitar but she wasn't
just playing it she was
jumping she was living i was like oh my
god she is my girl
right oh yeah i jumped i got the whole
bandage up
everybody was jumping the only thing i
didn't do was play behind my back which
i also know
oh you know how to play behind your back
oh my gosh that's next
what is the biggest thing you've gotten
out of this this switch in your life
coming to the hisida community a very
clear
sense of purpose a very clear
sense that i have i'm here for a reason
i know i mean and i forget about it
sometimes everybody
has problems with you know feeling down
and sorry for yourself but
i don't let it go beyond a certain point
because i know
that's not gonna last number one i'll
come out of it tomorrow
and then i'll go back on track to what i
need to be doing
because hashem has me here for a very
specific reason
we have each of us has different
fingerprints
think about that for a second that's
mind-blowing
nobody has the same fingerprints as me
you or you
nobody nobody uh chinese puerto rican
russian we all have different
fingerprints
what do you think about that for a
second it means we all have our reason
to be here
everybody everybody
all right this is my cute little hideout
so this is
by the way these are hooks how cute are
these hooks
ikea six dollars all right
meet my little studio
this is where i give my classes i'm
going to rob some overall books
instructor i'm a dance teacher and i do
something called
kosher zumba which is um
like dancer size it's basically zumba
but kosher in that the movements are a
little more refined
and the music is not so risque
you know it's a little more conservative
the music also i give classes on a
trampoline
which are great for the joints but it's
an unbelievable workout
so you know as i'm getting older and i
want to stay fit my whole life because
i pray to god all the time just keep me
fit so i can keep doing what i'm doing
which is
teaching girls to dance and whatever so
i need to think about my joints so
trampoline is softening the joints just
saying
what's the what's the age range who
comes here what age what ages uh
anywhere from
eight years old to i have some 15 60
year olds in my classes
of course the classes are you know um
age-appropriate
of course and this this by the way uh is
your back garage yeah this is my garage
their house is over there the family's
house is there and the garage is here
and you set it up very nicely yeah so i
feed my kids snapper and i say bye kids
i'm going to give a class and i fly out
to the garage
and i give my class and i come inside
sweating hopping okay so where were we
did you do your homework what's going on
next you know it's like i don't have to
go too far i'm giving my classes
so this is us that's great
um i feel like it's it's important for
people to before you make an assumption
about a community
get to go into the community right i
had preconceived notions about many
different things in my life that once i
got to know
you know better it's like it's like when
you meet somebody
you don't know who they are until you
get to know them and then all of a
sudden they become beautiful
right you know you meet somebody and you
don't think they're so pretty
yeah you get to know their personality
yeah right
that's a big it's a big teaching um in
our religion we believe that beauty
comes from within
yeah you can meet somebody and you know
that's why there's not such a big stress
on
you know that's why you know our
clothing
keeps us covered because beauty does
come from within
right so your point is before you judge
a community
spend some time in it talk to the people
in it
seems like common sense right absolutely
don't don't believe
the sound bites or right uh just
you the only truth i guess is through
your own eyes
right that is true and if you i mean
this is seeing that you can see that
you're right with your right so with
that said milk you've been awesome thank
you so much
thank you thank you all for watching
this
i think uh well i did my best to sort of
bring this energy that i've felt in
these neighborhoods
out to the world i think you're doing
great thank you thank you
for coming in here and um being nosy
curious i'm curious i always want to
know what's around the next corner
everywhere so you're making movies but
you don't have a link
online right so my performances are for
women and girls only um you'll find it
in
stores where you have to come to the
neighborhood yeah in the neighborhood
okay okay come to the neighborhood sure
it's okay no one's taking video of you
it's taking a video
end of the road uh if you want to
support this channel i got a link below
patreon page
dming uh behind the scenes footage if
you want to get in touch with me
go there i want to support the channel
and thanks for coming along
that was fun amazing amazing amazing
just cool go in and listen to people go
talk to people the world's not as scary
as everyone
tells you it is okay until the next one
okay
it's the wall check out
i love this wall it just signifies what
brooklyn is it's beautiful